this week we've been highlighting the
never ending cycle of violence in
democrat-run cities places like chicago
led by liberal lori lightfoot have
already seen
474 homicides this year and it's only
august even small cities like albany
georgia can't escape the horrors a
nine-year-old nigel brown was murdered
in his bed this weekend during a
drive-by shooting but brave residents of
these cities aren't waiting for their
leaders to stop the bloodshed and albany
city commissioner candidate jalen
johnson has raised ten thousand dollars
to help bring the killer of nigel brown
to justice while in chicago jalissa ford
is working to honor her late son
janari who was killed by gunfire last
year at only nine years old to her
foundation one jar foundation she's
working to combat the carnage in her
city jaylen johnson jalissa ford join me
now
miss ford uh we are so sorry for your
loss
you took that pain and you directed it
toward helping the community
what made you do that
yes um my son was always that child that
wanted to give back to his friends and
wanted to be there helping one
and to live out his legacy i started
just being more involved with my
community with helping the kids in the
community just have a better opportunity
and a safety net to have a chance to
grow up
yeah
jalen i want to go to you
nigel brown was killed drive-by shooting
in the bed living
his life
you decided to step up to the plate
because no one was coming up and
offering solutions or trying to get the
killer and you decided to offer a reward
what has been the response been are you
getting tips in what are you seeing on
the ground
thank you for that lawrence i first want
to say that i am praying for nigel
brown's family uh the incident that
happened with nine-year-old nigel brown
in albany georgia this weekend was a
complete tragedy and i'm praying for
them i decided to step up to the plate
because our leaders quite frankly are
asleep at the wheel i decided to donate
ten thousand dollars of my own money to
the albany area crime stoppers to help
bring a suspect to light in the murder
of our youth this is ridiculous this
should never happen to any mother in the
united states of america kids should be
untouchable and they should be able to
live grow and play and the community has
seen that young people like myself who's
also running for city commission in
albany have been able to step up and
offer tangible results to these uh
problems that we have in our community
instead of offering empty uh solutions
and i'm willing to fight for our
community
jalissa i just see the picture of your
son and
i got to ask you when you talk to the
leaders that are out there
do you get any closure from them do they
do you feel like this is going to take a
turn
what is it like out there
in the community that i'm from it's it's
devastating you know because we do have
community leaders out there um but
we need more of a voice for our
communities you know and we don't have
that and that's why i've been trying to
advocate for our community with giving a
better opportunity to our community for
our safety because we don't have any
jaleesa what does the one jar do what
does that foundation focus on
one jar foundation is a not-for-profit
organization
that i created in honor of my son
and what one jar does is
just giving back to the community and
i'm focusing on the kids the children of
the community and the youth and just
giving them an opportunity to be kids
you know
yeah
jalen what is your message for the
leaders that are out there you're
running for office you're a young man
yourself you are in the halls of capital
living your dream you're from albany you
decided to step up and run for office in
your camp in your town
what is your message for the people
yeah
look i worked on capitol hill for a
wonderful congress member and i decided
to move back permanently to my hometown
of albany georgia to step up to the
plate
and take this opportunity for one for my
family and also the residents of albany
georgia because we've already had 11
homicides this year that is insane we
should be able to live and grow together
without fear for our lives i want to
tell every leader in my hometown that
it's time to step up to the plate and
take on the challenge that we can
protect our citizens without defunding
the police we need to come to the table
with tangible solutions
to offer our citizens what they deserve
and i'm willing to do that so that's the
reason i came back to run yeah and this
is happening all across the country you
know
jaylen jalissa
a lot of people talk about it but you
guys have been about it thank you all so
much for coming on the program